[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
[Applaus]
Jubel für die ukrainischen Soldaten im
Zentrum von Hassan der Moment auf den
die Menschen hier seit Monaten gehofft
haben auf die Befreiung ihrer Stadt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
guten Abend der heutige Tag markiert ein
weiteres militärisches Desaster für den
Kreml die schnelle Einnahme der
strategisch wichtigen Gebietshauptstadt
hassson Anfang März war Putins größter
kriegserfolg wo gerade mal sechs Wochen
hat er noch verkündet das rassun für
immer russisch sein werde jetzt dort
abziehen zu müssen ist seine bislang
größte Niederlage darüber sprechen wir
gleich noch zunächst berichtete Sarah
Hassan Sade über die Befreiung von
rasson
feiern sie bis in die Dunkelheit Freuden
Tänze von ukrainischen Soldaten die seit
Sommer an der Großoffensive beteiligt
waren mit Menschen die monatelang unter
der russischen Besatzung gelitten hatten
bedächtiger ist die Stimmung in Kiew und
Präsident selensky betont am Tag des
Triumphes dass die Ukraine nicht ganz
befreit ist
so war es in allen anderen Städten die
unsere ABE befreit hatte und so wird es
auch in den Städten sein die wir noch
befreien und wo die Menschen auf unsere
Rückkehr warten die Ukraine wird zu
allen ihren Bürgern kommen aufgrund
unserer Stärke auf dem Schlachtfeld und
in der Diplomatie wir werden die Einheit
unseres Staates wiederherstellen
diese Bilder zeigen wie ein Teil der
russischen Soldaten den Fluss knipro
überquerte zu Fuß über eine
Behelfsbrücke und doch rechnet die
ukrainische Armee damit das noch
tausende russische Soldaten in herson
sein können viele Russen konnten den
knipro nicht überqueren sie werfen ihre
Uniformen weg ziehen Zivilkleidung an
und versuchen sich zu verstecken sie
werden Provokationen in Version
vorbereiten es gibt noch viel zu tun
im Umland von herrson haben sie ein
russisches Waffendepot gefunden die
Angst vor Minen und Sprengfallen ist
groß die ukrainische Armee konnte erst
einen gesicherten Zugang in die Stadt
herson errichten
ich weiß und verstehe dass jeder sehr
sein Zuhause vermisst seine Verwandten
und Freunde aber ich flehe sie an warten
Sie noch etwas ich flehe sie an es ist
einfach noch viel zu früh nach Herr von
zurückzukehren
angebunden die antonifkabrücke liegt den
Trümmern nach ihrem Rückzug hat die
russische Armee sie vollends gesprengt
aber das ist heute die kleinste Sorge
der Menschen in Rasse
bedeutet das Militär strategisch darüber
wollen wir mit Claudia major sprechen
sicherheits- und militärexpertin von der
Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik in
Berlin guten Abend Frau major guten
Abend wie wichtig ist razon also
irgendeine Stadt ist es jedenfalls nicht
nein Person ist in der Tat strategisch
wichtig weil es de facto das Tor zu
chronischen Schwarzmeerküste und zu
Odessa ist das war der einzige
Brückenkopf den Russland auf der
Westseite des nipro hatte da sind sie
jetzt zurückgezogen das heißt dass ein
Angriff Richtung Odessa und die und die
schwarzmarktküste immer
unwahrscheinlicher wird es liegt auch
diese Wasserversorgung der Krim
anrichson das heißt es ist wirklich
strategisch wichtig und ich glaube man
kann nicht genug betonen wie wichtig das
auch wirklich politisch symbolisch ist
weil das hatten sie auch gesagt die
einzige
Regionalhauptstadt war und Russland
hatte behauptet diese Gebiete annektiert
zu haben das heißt weniger Wochen nach
der an Aktion müssen Sie die dieses
Gebiet Räumen das ist schon eine
schallende Niederlage für Russland
sitzen die Russen quasi auf der einen
Seite des Flusses ist nepre den sie eben
auch erwähnten und man hört so aus
Russland zumindestens von den
Propagandisten dein naja also eine das
ist eine verlorene Schlacht aber deshalb
ist der Krieg noch nicht verloren wie
ist die militärische Situation für die
Russen jetzt einzuschätzen
es ist glaube ich wirklich wichtig zu
sagen dass Russland zwar geschwächt ist
das ist aber sich nicht geschlagen hat
Klang gegeben hat und auch nicht von
seinen Zielen abgewichen hat das ist
enorm wichtig weder politisch der
kremmelsprecher peschkov hat gesagt dass
die speziale Operation weitergeht und
Personen immer noch zu Russland gehört
und auch praktisch sehen wir das
Russland die Ostseite des Nepper
befestigt hat mit Bunker mit
Befestigungsanlagen dort also die neue
Frontlinie verlaufen wird dass auch die
Kämpfe im Osten denn jetzt und Johannes
weitergehen und das auch die aktive
endokrinisierungspolitik in den
besetzten Gebieten weitergeht also
Russland ist geschwächt das hat aber
seine Ziele nicht verändert und deshalb
müssen wir davon ausgehen dass sobald
sich die Truppen erhöht erholt haben
Russland auch wieder losschlagen wird
beschießt ja auch weiterhin also es hat
jetzt nicht irgendwie die
Kriegshandlungen eingestellt aber es
zeigt sich doch immerhin sage ich mal
auch Herr Putin ist in der Lage einen
Rückzug anzutreten
ja und da sehen wir auch einen großen
Unterschied zwischen dem Rückzug in in
fachkifft dass er kein Rückzug war
sondern eigentlich eine Flucht war und
das war ein Rückzug mit Ankündigung weil
der russische Befehlshaber schon im
Mitte Oktober sagte wir sind in der
schwierigen Situation stehen schwierige
Entscheidungen an wir können die Truppen
nicht mehr versorgen das heißt sie haben
versucht diesen Rückzug deutlich
geordneter zu machen und nicht mehr
diesen Eindruck zu erwecken sie müssten
da fliehen man muss aber trotzdem sagen
dass man einen Schritt zurückgeht sieht
man den Abzug aus Kiew im März den den
Abzug von raus rachkiff jetzt den
Artikel aus rachson das heißt es ist
eine lange Liste von russischen
Niederlagen ist diese Abzug wir wissen
noch nicht genau was in der Nacht alles
passiert ist es kommen ja auch
Informationen immer erst nach und nach
aber manche haben erwartet dass es dann
am diesen Flussufer wo die Russen auch
ein großer Zahl eingekesselt zu sein
schienen ein regelrechtes Massaker geben
würde ein komplettes blutbutton ein
chaotische Abzug das war ja nicht so
anscheinend wie sie es auch beschrieben
haben da gibt es jetzt manche Stimmen
die vermuten dass es Absprachen gegeben
hat zwischen Ukrainern halten Sie das
für wahrscheinlich ich kann das nicht
bestätigen es gab ja viel mehr Berichte
dass es sehr wohl
Beschuss auf die russischen Truppen
gegeben hat und ich gehe auch davon aus
dass die Ukraine weiterhin zu sagen die
russischen Truppen dort schlagen oder
dort bekämpfen wird wo sie es können
also ich kann mir nicht so recht
vorstellen dass es dort Absprachen
gegeben hat
danke für die Einschätzung für das
Gespräch sehr gerne
hierzulande bahnt sich derweil ein neuer
Konflikt an zwischen dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister und mehreren
Bundesländern wegen der
isolationspflicht für corona-infiziert
bisher galt ja dass man nach einem
positiven Test wenigstens in den ersten
fünf Tagen zu Hause bleibt und nicht zur
Arbeit oder in die Schule geht diese
Regel werden vier Bundesländer jedoch
aufheben und das wohl schon nächste
Woche nur medizinisches Personal soll
ausgenommen sein dafür hat sich neben
Baden-Württemberg Hessen und
Schleswig-Holstein auch Bayern
entschieden wo ja früher mal Team
Vorsicht regierte von dort berichtet
Cordelia Strauß
wer krank ist soll zu Hause bleiben das
gilt für alle Krankheiten auch für eine
covid 19 Infektion mit Symptomen wer
infiziert ist aber keine Symptome hat
muss sich in Bayern ab Mittwoch nicht
mehr isolieren lediglich das Tragen
einer Maske ist dann außerhalb der
Wohnung Pflicht wir sind an einer
anderen Situation jetzt angekommen an
einem Übergang zu Endemie wie viele
Experten auch bestätigen klar ist bei
medizinischen und pflegerischen
Einrichtungen werden wir weiterhin
Betretungsverbote tätigkeitsverbote in
bestimmten Bereichen lassen weil wir
dort die vulnerablen Gruppen besonders
schützen wollen manche ältere Bürger und
Menschen mit Vorerkrankungen fürchten
nun einer größeren gesundheitlichen
Gefahr ausgesetzt zu sein viele
Fachleute teilen diese Sorge nicht die
behördliche angeordnete Isolation und
quarantänisierung also Absonderung
begründet sich ja vor allem darin dass
man eine gemeingefährliche Erkrankung
aus der Öffentlichkeit fernhalten möchte
tatsächlich ist durch die gestiegene im
unkompetenz der Bevölkerung covid 19
heute medizinischer Sicht mehr denn je
mit anderen Atemwegserkrankungen
vergleichbar hier gehen die
Expertenmeinungen deutlich auseinander
so gibt es für Bundesgesundheitsminister
Karl Lauterbach keinen medizinischen
Grund jetzt auf die isolationspflicht zu
verzichten wir haben derzeit etwa 1000
Todesfälle durch koved pro Woche wir
sind vor einer wahrscheinlich schweren
winterwelle weil die bq1.1 Variante sich
stärker ausbreitet wir müssen auch
bedenken dass viele Menschen im
Arbeitsprozess wenn sie sich infizieren
long-zahlen begrenzen und die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
schützen und nicht gefährden wenn
Mitarbeitende infiziert sind aber nicht
krank wer entscheidet ob sie zur Arbeit
kommen sollen oder nicht die Aufhebung
der isolationspflicht stellt Arbeitgeber
vor neuer Herausforderungen
ich muss die betrieblichen Belange also
meine Fürsorgepflicht die ich nach wie
vor natürlich jetzt erst recht als
Arbeitgeber habe abwägen mit dem
Belangen der Belegschaft ich muss den
Gesundheitsschutz neu prüfen und ich
muss mich gegebenenfalls mit dem
Betriebsrat also der
Arbeitnehmervertretung neu einigen
unklar ist auch was das nun für
Berufspendler zwischen den Bundesländern
bedeutet wenn dort unterschiedliche
Regeln gelten wenn Fachleute sich
streiten verunsichert dass die Bürger
oft die Auseinandersetzung über die
Aufhebung der isolationspflicht hat
gerade erst begonnen
und jetzt macht Heinz Wolf weiter mit
den Nachrichten in einer stundenlangen
Nachtsitzung hat der Haushaltsausschuss
des Bundestages über den etafel 2023
beraten schließlich gab es eine Einigung
auf einen Bundeshaushalt von
476,3 Milliarden Euro mit neuen Krediten
von
45,6 Milliarden darin nicht enthalten
sind weitere Milliarden Kredite etwa für
die Strom- und gaspreisbremse
der Bundestag hat dem vorübergehenden
Weiterbetrieb der drei letzten
Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland zugestimmt
zur Sicherung der Stromversorgung dürfen
die Kraftwerke bis Mitte April nächsten
Jahres am Netz bleiben im Zuge des
Atomausstiegs hätten sie eigentlich zum
Jahresende abgeschaltet werden sollen
US-Präsident beiden hat in einer Rede
bei der UN Klimakonferenz in Sharm
el-Sheikh noch einmal die
Entschlossenheit der USA im Kampf gegen
den Klimawandel unterstrichen die USA
würden ihr für 2030 gesetztes Ziel einer
Reduzierung der
Treibhausgasemissionen um mindestens 50%
einhalten neue Zusagen in der Frage der
finanziellen Hilfen für klimabedingte
Schäden eine Forderung der
Entwicklungsländer machte beiden
allerdings nicht
bundesverteidigungsministerin Lamprecht
hat in Schwielowsee bei Potsdam den
wiederaufgebauten Ehrenhain der
Bundeswehr eröffnet dort wird der 59
Soldaten gedacht die im Zusammenhang mit
dem Einsatz in Afghanistan gestorben
sind
zentrales Element des ehrenhains ist ein
Gedenkstein der aus einem Feldlager der
Bundeswehr in Afghanistan im vergangenen
Jahr nach Deutschland gebracht worden
war
zwischen Italien und Frankreich gibt es
Streit in der Flüchtlingspolitik das
zuletzt in Italien abgewiesene
seenotrettungsschiff Ocean Viking mit
mehr als 200 Migranten an Bord konnte
heute in der französischen Hafenstadt
Toulon anlegen Frankreichs Innenminister
sprach von einer ausnahmeentscheidung
und kritisierte die Haltung Italiens
Ministerpräsidentin Meloni verteidigte
ihre Linie und forderte eine neue
europäische Lösung
Europa steht derzeit natürlich ganz im
Bann des Krieges in der Ukraine und der
Bedrohungen die von Russland ausgehen
darauf schaut man in anderen
Weltregionen zwar auch aber mit viel
mehr Distanz in Asien etwa gilt die
größere Sorge anderen Konflikten allen
voran der expansionstrank Chinas der
ewige kurierkonflikt und seit geraumer
Zeit die blutige Gewalt in Myanmar
die Lage dort ist aktuell eines der
Hauptthemen auf dem asian-gipfel die
südostasiatische Staatengemeinschaft mit
ihren zehn Mitgliedern trifft sich
derzeit in Kambodscha morgen wird auch
US-Präsident beiden dort erwartet im
vergangenen Jahr hatten die asianstaaten
einen Friedensplan für Myanmar
erarbeitet der aber von der dortigen
Militär herunter nicht umgesetzt wird
Norman Odenthal berichtet
weit in den Himmel steigt der Rauch
kündet von Tragödien am Boden Häuser
brennen ganze Dörfer überall in Myanmar
immer wieder internationale Beobachter
haben keine Zweifel das sind die Taten
des Militärs es macht Jagd auf
Oppositionelle setzt dabei auf Angst und
Schrecken hunderttausende sind über die
Grenze nach Thailand geflohen oder
verstecken sich im eigenen Land
mein Cousin wurde auf offener Straße
erschossen an seiner Leiche haben
Soldaten eine Mine befestigt wer die
Leiche bergen wollte sollte sterben
einer hat dann versucht den Körper mit
einem langen Stock zu bewegen die Mine
ging sofort hoch wir haben nur
Leichenteile zurückbekommen
das auszusprechen diese Bilder der
Zerstörung aus dem Land zu schmuggeln
schon das ist lebensgefährlich
die Unterdrückung die Brutalität des
Militärs gegen das eigene Volk so etwas
hat es noch nicht gegeben aber die
Menschen in Myanmar wieder setzen sich
weiter halten dagegen und das so
deutlich muss man das sagen obwohl sie
aus dem Ausland so gut wie keine
Unterstützung bekommen
der asian-gipfel in Phnom Pen könnte das
ändern der südostasiatische Staatenbund
ist kein einheitlicher Block aber
gemeinsame Interessen gibt es sehr wohl
politisch wirtschaftlich Frieden ist nun
mal besser fürs Geschäft der Gastgeber
macht klar worum es geht
wir stehen an einem Punkt der
Ungewissheit Millionen Menschen leben in
unserer Region sind angewiesen auf
unsere Weisheit und unsere Weitsicht
alles hängt davon ab dass wir die
richtigen Entscheidungen treffen
das lässt sich auf viele Probleme Münzen
auf den Myanmar Konflikt allemal
Indonesiens Präsident wird deutlich
indonesien ist extrem enttäuscht die
Situationen Myanmar verschlechtert sich
weiter es gibt keine nennenswerten
Fortschritt in der Umsetzung unserer
Vereinbarung für ein Ende der Gewalt die
Militär unter zeigt sich nicht gewillt
diesen Plan zu folgen
das soll die Strafe sein ein Lehrer
Stuhl Vertreter der Militär unter
Myanmar sind ausgeladen demonstrativ
eingeladen dagegen sind morgen die USA
China Russland mächtige Gäste also die
jedoch sicher nicht an einem Strang
ziehen stattdessen kommen damit fraglos
neue Konflikte auf die Tagesordnung
der Fall Myanmar kann nur auf solchen
hochrangigen Gipfeltreffen diskutiert
werden nur da kann man Lösungen finden
allerdings sind viele Leute in Myanmar
mutlos zynisch sagen sie dass sei nur
blablabla und bringe nichts aber es ist
trotzdem ganz wichtig dass Myanmar auf
der internationalen Tagesordnung bleibt
denn da ist so etwas wie Konkurrenz mit
anderen Krisen und Kriegen und myan Mars
Militär herunter dürfte das nicht
Unrecht sein im Schatten operiert sie
weiter mit aller Gewalt
im Schatten anderer Konflikte würden
auch die Gewaltherrscher in Iran gerne
stehen aber die Welt schaut trotzdem hin
was natürlich auch daran liegt dass die
Protestierenden Iranerinnen und Iraner
sehr aktiv das Internet nutzen um die
Außenwelt zu informieren und
aufzurütteln hinzu kommen iranische
prominente insbesondere Sportler die
nicht davor zurückschrecken
international Zeichen zu setzen und eine
in der westlichen Welt weit verstreute
aber gut organisierte große
auslandsopposition der ist immer wieder
gelingt Massen auf die Straßen zu
bringen so auch in Deutschland kann man
safiari an und Jasmin astaki bardei
berichten
sie singen die Hymne der Proteste in
Iran 17.000 Menschen solidarisieren sich
gestern Abend in Köln mit den Protesten
im Gottesstaat
[Musik]
er hat zehntausende zur größten
iran-demo in Berlin zusammengebracht
Ikone der iranischen auslandsopposition
sein Verdienst er hat die
Oppositionsgruppen vereint seine
Botschaft der
westerne Regierung müssen begreifen in
Iran findet gerade eine Revolution statt
sie sollten jegliche Verhandlungen mit
dem Regime beenden auch den atomdeal
angesichts der blutigen
Menschenrechtsverletzungen dort außerdem
sollten Sie eine deutliche politische
Botschaft senden nämlich alle iranischen
Botschafter ausweisen
den Kanada lebt ist gut vernetzt
mobilisiert auch Regierungschefs wie
Justin trido den teheran hat ismaelions
Familie auf dem Gewissen Januar 2020
beim Abschluss einer ukrainischen
Passagiermaschine in Teheran sterben
esmaillions Frau parison und seine
einzige Tochter Rida
erst nach Tagen gibt Iran den Abschuss
zu bisher ist niemand zur Rechenschaft
gezogen worden
das ist
zerreißt mir das Herz jeden Tag
[Musik]
nach Frauen meine Tochter getötet haben
habe ich versprochen nicht aufzugeben am
Anfang dachte ich ich wäre alleine wir
haben uns aber alle zusammen getan und
aus einem kleinen Rinnsal ist ein großer
Fluss geworden
also bekommen
will dass Iran zur Verantwortung gezogen
wird auch für Kamikaze Drohnen die es in
Russland geliefert hat doch Teheran
setzt inzwischen auf einer Allianz mit
Russland der Chef des russischen
Sicherheitsrates patruschef war zuletzt
den Teheran Expertenwissen dahinter
steckt politisches
kalkült viele Erwartungen an Russland es
soll Iran in schwierigen Zeiten helfen
dazu gehört die Sanktionen des Westens
zu umgehen außerdem soll Russland Iran
bei der Niederschlagung der Proteste im
Innern helfen
auch heute wieder Bilder landesweiter
Proteste wie hier in soredan oder
Wanderer Boss Drohungen des iranischen
Außenministers wegen deutscher Kritik am
Vorgehen gegen die Proteste weist die
Außenministerin zurück so wie
Menschenrechte für mich universell
gelten und nicht und teilbar sind so
sind Drohungen für mich kein Mittel der
Außenpolitik und der internationalen
Beziehung
Hamid ismaelion sagt er habe einen Traum
dass keine Kinder mehr in Iran getötet
werden
und dass der Wind der Freiheit durch die
Haare der Frauen weht der
winds hair
aber die Proteste in Iran und die Rolle
der auslandsopposition spricht wohl
schmiese nachher im heute journal Update
mit dem iranisch stämmigen grünen
Vorsitzenden um mit Nuri pur und jetzt
noch mal eins zunächst mit dem Blick auf
die Wirtschaft der Statistische
Bundesamt hat seine erste Schätzung zur
Inflationsrate im Oktober bestätigt sie
ist in Deutschland auf 10,4 Prozent
gestiegen dagegen haben die USA gestern
für die Teuerungsrate dort eine
Abschwächung gemeldet Stefanie berrett
wie erklärt sich dieser Unterschied ja
in den USA scheint der Höhepunkt der
Inflation überschritten denn die
Amerikaner müssen einfach deutlich
weniger teure Energie am Weltmarkt
einkaufen als Europa das im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes auch unter einer
importierten Inflation leidet Kosten für
Energie und Nahrungsmittel sind nach wie
vor die Preistreiber Nummer eins gut 20
Prozent mehr als noch vor einem Jahr
mussten Verbraucher im Oktober für
Lebensmittel ausgeben Spitzenreiter
dabei Speisefette und Öle mit einem
saftigen Preisaufschlag von 50 Prozent
Molkereiprodukte und Eier fast 30 und
Brot rund 20% teurer Energieprodukte
legten im Vergleich zum Vorjahr im
Schnitt um 43% zu Gas mit einer
Steigerung von mehr als 100% gleich
verdoppelt doch es gibt auch Grund zur
Hoffnung aktuell sehen wir bei Heizöl
und Diesel eine überraschende
Entspannung seit Mitte Oktober fällt der
Preis für Heizöl um
21%. wie auch insgesamt die Preise an
einigen Energiemärkten nachgeben als
Gründe führen Experten gut gefüllte
Gasspeicher an sowie die vielen noch vor
Europas Küsten wartenden Schiffe mit
Flüssiggas für allgemeine Entwarnung am
Energiemarkt vermutlich noch zu früh und
bis die Preise in Deutschland auf
breiter Front wieder fallen dürfte es
märz werden dann greift nämlich die
gaspreisbremse der DAX gegen diese Woche
ganz von der Bremse und legt eine
dynamische Wochenbilanz von fast sechs
Prozent hin der nachlassende Preis- und
zinsdruck in den USA er macht die Aktien
wieder attraktiver und Anleger greifen
zu Stefanie berrett vielen Dank gerne
der Journalist und Sprachkritiker Wolf
Schneider ist gestorben im Alter von 97
Jahren in Starnberg Schneider leitete
unter anderem die Henry nannten
Journalistenschule in Hamburg und hatte
führende Positionen bei bekannten
deutschen Medienhäusern inne mit Büchern
wie Deutsch für Profis wurde er
deutschlandweit als Experte für Sprache
und Stil bekannt
eine Meldung vom Sport das deutsche
frauenfußball-nationalteam konnte einem
Prestige Erfolg feiern bei den
Weltmeisterinnen aus den USA vor fast
17.000 Zuschauern in Fort Lauderdale
gingen die deutschen zunächst glücklich
in Führung den Amerikanerinnen gelangen
nach einem intensiven Schlagabtausch
durch Superstar Megan repino der später
Ausgleich aber kurz vor Schluss des
temporeichen Testspiels schafft die
eingewechselte Paulina krombiegel dann
das Siegtor zum 2:1
in den Karnevalshochburgen am Rhein hat
die fünfte dinerische Jahreszeit
begonnen und zwar weitgehend ohne
corona-beschränkungen
drei eins pünktlich um 11 Uhr 11 gab es
den traditionellen Startschuss viele
tausend Menschen schunkelten sich in
Feierlaune in Köln musste wegen des
großen Antrags sogar der Zugang zum
beliebten Zülpicher Viertel beschränkt
werden etwas ruhiger aber nicht weniger
närrisch kann es in Mainz zu
das war es im heute-journal und es geht
direkt weiter mit dem neuen ZDF
Politbarometer Antje Pieper präsentiert
Ihnen die Ergebnisse
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer knapp 20 Jahre ist sie
hier die Geburtsstunde der harzreform
ihr Ziel die hohe Arbeitslosigkeit
bekämpfen jetzt soll Hartz 4 Weg das
Bürgergeld dafür kommen das hat der
Bundestag erst gestern beschlossen die
nächste Hürde ist der Bundesrat
das Bürgergeld soll die große
Sozialreform der Ampelkoalition sein die
Begeisterung jedoch hält sich in Grenzen
nur 35 Prozent finden das neue
Bürgergeld eher gut schlecht finden es
dagegen 58 Prozent die Kritik zulässt
das Bürgergeld biete Arbeitslosen zu
wenig Anreiz einen neuen Job zu suchen
finden 68% der Befragten berechtigt 26
Prozent teilen die Kritik nicht
die Kritik war vor allem aus den Reihen
von cdu/csu laut geworden die jetzt mit
einer Blockade im Bundesrat drohen
insgesamt liegt die Union in der
Wählergunst weiter vorn wenn am nächsten
Sonntag wirklich Bundestagswahl wäre
käme die SPD auf 19%. CDU und CSU sind
weiter die stärkste Kraft 28 beide
unverändert die Grünen legen etwas zu 22
FDP etwas weniger 5 AFD 15 die Linke 5
Prozent ebenfalls beide unverändert
das bedeutet weiter keine Mehrheit für
die Ampel und auch sonst zeigt sich die
Zufriedenheit mit der Arbeit der
Regierung ist weiter gering und trotzdem
nur knapp jeder Fünfte meint dass eine
unionsgeführte Bundesregierung den Job
insgesamt besser machen würde
schauen wir auf unsere Top Ten also die
Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung auf das Skala von
+5 bis -5 ist Alice Weidel Schlusslicht
mit extrem negativen minus 2,5 davor
Sahra Wagenknecht minus 0,8 bei der
etwas besser als zuletzt Christine
Lambrecht jetzt wieder in den Top Ten
-0,5 Friedrich Merz -0,4 Christian
Lindner und Markus Söder minus 0,2 alles
schlechter auch Karl Lauterbach verliert
jetzt 0,1 Olaf Scholz wird den stärksten
Verlusten 0,5 etwas verbessern konnte
sich Robert Habeck auf 0,9 auf Platz 1
erstmals Anna-Lena beerburg mit 1,0
leichte Zugewinne
die Grünen Vertreter profitieren auch
weil ihre Partei die größte Kompetenz
beim Klima zugeschrieben wird und das
ist gerade in den Schlagzeilen noch bis
Ende nächster Woche tagt die
Weltklimakonferenz in Ägypten heute kam
der wohl prominenteste Gast US-Präsident
Joe Biden große Namen wichtige Themen
und wenig Zuversicht denn das dort
wirklich was für den Klimaschutz
erreicht wird davon geht nur ein sehr
kleiner Teil der Befragten aus 67% sind
der Meinung auf der Konferenz würde nur
wenig erreicht 23 Prozent glauben sogar
sie bringe überhaupt nichts
so klären jedenfalls gibt es viel zum
Beispiel wie Industrie Länder die vor
allem für den Klimawandel verantwortlich
sind
ärmere Nationen unterstützen können
fast dreiviertel sind der Meinung die
Industriestaaten sollen den ärmeren
Ländern mehr zahlen damit diese die
Folgen des Klimawandels besser
bewältigen können 20% sind dagegen
fakt ist um den Klimawandel einzudämmen
muss etwas passieren global und auf
nationaler Ebene
die Politik in Deutschland allerdings
macht für mehr als die Hälfte zu wenig
für den Klimaschutz noch weniger die
Unternehmen die Befragten üben aber auch
Selbstkritik 63% sagen die Bürger selbst
machen zu wenig fürs Klima
trotz aller Dringlichkeit die in letzter
Zeit zunehmenden illegalen Aktionen von
klimaaktivisten zum Beispiel
Straßenblockaden gehen für die große
Mehrheit zu weit
fast nahtlos an die Weltklimakonferenz
reiht sich Ende nächster Woche die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft der Männer in
Katar seit gestern steht auch der
deutsche Kader fest doch statt der
gewohnten Fußball Euphorie dominiert
Kritik diese vor wm-phase
nur 39% aller Befragten finden es
richtig dass die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft an dieser WM
teilnimmt 53% finden das nicht richtig
das Jahr neigt sich dem Ende zu von
besinnlichem Jahresendspurt ist bisher
allerdings nicht viel zu spüren die
Politik bleibt unter stetigen Zugzwang
das Klima verändert sich rasend schnell
und die Menschenrechte das zeigt die WM
nicht zuletzt müssen immer wieder
verteidigt werden
das war das Politbarometer heute alle
Grafiken und Infos gibt es auch in der
ZDF heute App und wenn Sie wissen wollen
wie die Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe
Wahlen zustande kommen dann finden Sie
alle Informationen unter
politbarometer.zdf.de
das nächste reguläre Politbarometer gibt
es am 25 November hier folgt jetzt das
Wetter und dann die heute-show einen
schönen Abend noch auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend so milde November
Temperaturen bei uns die können schon
mal verwirren auch eine japanische
schneekirsche die fing glatt an zu
blühen und lockte eine Biene an
besonders schön sieht das natürlich aus
bei Sonnenschein und klar blauem Himmel
den werden wir jetzt morgen aber nicht
überall haben und das liegt an dem hoch
denn das bringt doch viel Nebel und
Hochnebel mit vor allen Dingen in den
Flusstälern Süddeutschlands und dieser
Nebel wird sich heute Nacht erstmal
wieder ausbreiten und auch dichter
werden in Norddeutschland ist es dagegen
meist klar an der Ostsee ziehen einige
Wolkenfelder vorbei und an der See
liegen die Temperaturen heute Nacht bei
11 bis 6 Grad sonst gehen sie auf +5 bis
-2 Grad zurück und die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen sind ganz
unterschiedlich wenn sich der Nebel zäh
hält dann werden kaum 7 Grad erreicht
mit leichter Föhn Unterstützung am
Nordrand von Harz oder auch Eifel gibt
es bei strahlendem Sonnenschein bis zu
17 Grad und in Norddeutschland ist es
morgen meist sonnig an der Ostsee ziehen
die Wolkenfelder vorbei und in
Süddeutschland wird das eine zähe
Angelegenheit ob sich da Nebel und
Hochnebel überall auflösen ist unklar es
kann auch bis zum Abend mal trüb bleiben
am Sonntag mischt dann ein Tief hier
über dem zentralen Mittelmeer sich
langsam bei uns ein das bringt dann zum
Montag den ersten Regen hier im
Südwesten und dieser Regen sieht dann am
Dienstag weiter nordwärts richtig
spannend wird es dann aber am Mittwoch
nämlich ein kräftiges Hoch über
Skandinavien einem Tief bei Island
gegenübersteht dann kann es von
Nordosten kalt werden oder von Südwesten
mild bleiben tschüss